terrestrial vertebrates are all
tetrapods
for luggage but terrestrial
invertebrates can have six eight ten or
more
what is it about having an internal
skeleton that limited ancestral
terrestrial vertebrates
vertebrates to evolving only four lambs
so that's i i love this question um and
i
um i ki i have sort of a kind of a
mechanistic answer
and i'm not sure i i feel like i would
like to spend
a week or so talking with people about
this rather than trying to do something
kind of
kind of off the top of my head what are
you looking at well i'm thinking back
through the phylogeny and trying to
figure out how much we're going to foist
off onto
historical constraint and how much we've
got a mechanistic
reason they're they look like they're
they sound like they're looking for a
mechanistic explanation i'm just trying
to
well one one of the levels of mechanism
has to do with hox genes yep um so
there's this there's a
big class of of genes called homeobox
genes within which
um is a category of genes called hox
genes sometimes those are conflated
actually often they're completed in fact
i found a paper by two
well-respected biologists today in which
they you know often
say like hawks parentheses homeobox or
the universe but no like hawks is a
subset of homeobox and hawks genes
specifically
are involved in basically um
repeating segments on the anterior
posterior axis
and so in in vertebrates you basically
have an axial skeleton an
axis sort of three skeletons
developmentally you've got an axial
skeleton
a cranial skeleton and then an
appendicular skeleton the up the
appendices
and exactly as the discord people are
are positing we've got two girdles we've
got two appendicular
um girdles the pectoral girdle up here
off which come our arms
and the pelvic girdle off which comb our
legs and that's actually
highly conserved across all
all vertebrates there are no you
when you get repeats when you get um
repeats that don't belong in the hogs
genes invertebrates
um at the you know sort of appendicular
girdle level
um those those hopeful monsters don't
survive
right they aren't they aren't that
hopeful um
but there it does seem to me that
there's something about the um
the the more repeats that are already in
the arthropod skeleton i don't know if
it's going to be an internal versus
external skeleton thing per se
but the fact that there are just already
more repeats um
and so the sort of you know at each at
each of the segments
off an arthropod skeleton you can kind
of do a repeat that involves legs
um or or not uh and
uh you know so there i sort of fizzle
out without having spent a lot more time
digging back into the
evo devo stuff that i i once kind of
knew but also i think we don't fully
understand you know like the
anterior posterior axis hox genes deal
with repeats
but you know what more than that yeah um
i have to say i don't have a good fix on
this there is something about
the arthropods with their many segments
that there
are bound to be simple rules for
animating those segments
yeah in other words simple patterns and
in fact uh those of us who have
experimented with
robot building find that you can you
know you can
create uh an insect or a spider and that
you know it's not so hard to figure out
a pattern that actually produces
locomotion
yeah um and there's something about
the fact of the vertebrates being
more software flexible
so the pattern that functions to produce
locomotion
is something that can be partially
acquired now obviously a horse locomotes
pretty well at birth
um a person does not
so how much flexibility there needs to
be
is a question but i'm wondering about so
you're you're talking
it's like a conservation of flexibility
like
if invertebrates which tend to have more
software control
um there might be less flexibility in
the hardware
side in this case the hawks genes it's a
lot easier to produce a vertebrate that
cannot figure out how to walk
rather than you know i'm thinking by
analogy
um i think i pointed some weeks ago to
vi hart's
analysis of fibonacci sequences in
plants and the basic point was nowhere
in the plants is there a description of
fibonacci sequence what there is is a
set of simple rules that results in
fibonacci sequences
that basically serve to get the leaves
out of each other's shadows so as you
change the form of a plant
you get a slight modification of where
the leaves come out but basically they
are repelled
they are chemically repelled from the
last from all the other leaves in such a
way that distributes them so that they
fill in whatever structure you've gotten
so the basic point is
you've got a system that as you change
the structure of a plant
distributes the leaves in some useful
way and i'm imagining that there might
be something similar
where as you um add legs
there's some mechanism for figuring out
how to coordinate them
and that this would be much harder to do
in
vertebrates therefore a conservation
where the way to locomote is a variation
on a known theme
yeah rather than a rapidly expanding
combinatorics problem
yeah might be the well there's also it's
it's
very rare invertebrates um to be able to
regenerate
limbs or digits it's it it is it exists
in some
in i think a couple of different
salamander clades we have in fact
had yes so for sure one salamander clay
but i think it's actually more than one
salamander clade so actually multiple
i think the evidence suggests i'm
recalling correctly well i
i think there may be multiple evolutions
of of this capacity but it is it is
restricted to i think caudates
to salamanders within um
at least within the tetrapods and i
think maybe within the vertebrates more
broadly whereas
um
everything about arthropods seems sort
of more segmented
like you know you everyone has seen like
harvest men which aren't spiders but are
related to spiders
daddy longlegs um having lost a leg and
still moving around fine sometimes
us three four or five legs even right
then they still do fine they don't you
know there's no need to staunch the
bleeding they just like it happens
um and vertebrates don't do nearly as
good a job of sealing off
things when they lose it when they lose
something well there's a question about
where this comes from though because um
so
we have noticed many times in the
tropics when you're running at a field
station that has some sort of lights
that stay on all night they
act as an inadvertent light trap and so
especially if you
lodge somewhere where you pass the same
wall every night you get a kind of a
sense of
who's coming out of the forest and it's
amazing how frequently
you encounter animals that are missing a
limb and still functioning
but it's all insects and arachnids right
but the point is all right these are
creatures that don't have
meaningful capacity for repair at all
right and so there's a question what
does selection see
when you know a spider has lost a limb
right it has no process by which to give
up and fairly frequently
a spider who has lost a limb and manages
will reproduce
so but that maybe its capacity for
repair that is the the sort of causal
agent that we're looking for rather than
external versus internal
that's exactly where i was going my
point is going to be
in the vertebrates we see the repair
capacity
tracking the viability of the creature
in repair and post repair so we see it i
think we've mentioned this
recently we see it in things like sloths
which fall out of trees and break a limb
and because they're not just a tree limb
right
they because their ecology
does not depend on them dodging
predators
through stealth or through speed
um you can actually get away with being
a
a a sloth with a bum limb
and survive through crypsis which is the
basic way that they avoid being eaten
so the point is there have been lots and
lots of sloths that have broken a limb
and then gone on to reproduce so there's
lots of capacity to repair
monkeys similarly and us right we have
lots of capacity
for that kind of repair but loss of limb
how often and so the point is why is
this capacity not augmented
the capacity to replace a limb i see one
of two paths one
limb loss is so devastating that you
don't tend to survive it and
leave offspring in the ancestral
environment and the other
which leans more in the direction of my
initial response here
is that we have to learn to use our
limbs
and so if you replaced a limb it's not
automatically clear that it would be so
useful just the same way as a blind
person who's been blind since birth
who suddenly gets sight doesn't
necessarily know what to do with the
information that there's
that's coming in their eyes because they
didn't go through the developmental
process that would teach them how to
deal with it so you know is the reason
that we can't regenerate our limbs
because
it's biologically impossible to create
that
or is it that it just has not been
useful so in the same way that a horse
doesn't have the capacity to repair a
broken leg very easily because very few
horses in the ancestral past ever
survived a broken leg because they would
get picked off by whatever predators
were present
it just never got augmented yeah and i
guess so not appendicular skeleton but
returning to axial skeleton
limb regeneration is very rare and let's
just
stick to tetrapods because i'm just less
sure about the um aquatic vertebrates
the the primarily aquatic vertebrates
ones that didn't return secondarily
um but um along the axial skeleton
caudal autotomy which is fancy language
for um
tail loss and regrowth is actually
fairly common
in the um in the squamates right which
is the
lizards and and snakes um where and
in fact they're they're definitely in
this case different evolutions of caudal
autonomy because in some cases it's
inter-vertebral
in some cases the when you know a
predator bites the tail
it's adaptively advantageous to drop the
tail and they'll leave
leave the tail moving while you escape
and the predators kind of mouth full of
tail
sometimes that break happens between the
vertebrae intervertebrally
and sometimes it's intravertibly
sometimes it's
actually it breaks a vertebra in half
yep
really so you know clearly different
different evolutions of caudal autonomy
which
um if you're if you're a yummy little
lizard um
or a snake uh there are there are
apparently many clades in which
um that was an adaptive all right thank
you
my ignorance is about to come to the
surface here i uh would have said that
there are no snakes that have caudal
autonomy are you telling me that there
are any yeah as i was saying i was like
i i think they're
i think they're saying but i'm not i'm
not positive and
you know why so i i have this i have a
sense of like why
there might not be you probably have a
sense of why they might are you just
saying
i've never seen it yeah uh my sense is
locomotory wise
it you know loss of a tail um is a big
deal no matter who you are if you had a
tail yeah um but for a snake
it's an even bigger deal because you're
using um
you know depending there's like these
five modes of locomotion and snakes but
regardless you're using your body on the
ground
to some degree and your tail is part of
that body on the ground and so yeah
lose your tail and you may actually um
be be really
incapable of getting around for a while
after that yeah although you could
grapple i mean i don't see any reason
that it shouldn't work but i think
the reason i guess i'm not expecting it
is the way
snakes are preyed upon may not make it
all that useful
right in other words if you're jumping
at a lizard
and the lizard is escaping it's not
uncommon that you
end up with its tail yeah it drops the
tail
and i'm thinking that might not be the
case with snakes that the way a predator
goes after a snake
a very quick search reveals the russian
journal of herpetology
from 1994
uh caudal autotomy and the cluebird
snake xenocrophis episcotator
no pisskater from vietnam uh the
abstract
uh which is not extensive a rare case of
caudal autonomy included snake from
vietnam is described
it is an intervertebral autotomy that
differs from the more commonly
encountered intravertebral autonomy
typical of most lizard species
distribution and origin of
intervertebral autonomy and squamates
are discussed so
does it say anything there about some
predator that would
then validate the uh trickier part of
the
hypothesis i just put forward um yeah i
i do not have the rights to the full
uh paper at the russian journal of
herpetology i'll have to you know try to
cy hub this later or something so
at the moment i'll have these
abstracting the references all you have
is the abstract which which is like two
sentences
you rush into conclusions which in a
scientific paper
are up front in the abstract
they are yes russian yeah conclusions
i'm right there yeah got it got it
not overwhelmed with the humor but not
no a rough week
yeah yeah
[Music]
you